we're all on our phones all the time
we're tweeting all the time we're
facebooking snapchatting what else is
there Instagram some ways booking tumblr
all of that stuff I'm working on my
tumblr my new one but did you know that
your bed is soon going to be part of
your technological lifestyle that's
right a new company called Luna is
making your sleep pattern as well take a
look Luna tracks the quality of your
sleep every night including your sleep
phases heart rate and breathing rate so
you can see how restful your sleep was
without having to wear anything to bed
Luna combines all this knowledge about
your night with information about your
day gathered from other sources like how
much exercise you got or what you ate
and uses those insights to recommend
what works best for your sleep for
example whenever you fall asleep Luna
will send a signal to your smart home
devices making sure your door is locked
TV and lights are off and your alarm is
set for the next morning Lunas built-in
smart alarm wakes you at the right
moment of light sleep helping you forget
about groggy mornings when you step out
of bed your Wi-Fi connected coffee
machine can start brewing automatically
so you always wake up to the smell of
fresh coffee all right so this is
seriously wild stuff I mean talk about
the real world and the internet kind of
combining into one super thing so Luna
is basically like a sheet that fits over
your bed and that's how it's reading all
of these metrics they're running an
IndieGoGo campaign right now which if
you get in on you can be you can buy it
for 179 bucks otherwise it's going to be
249 yeah I mean this actually it's like
all of this stuff when I talk about all
this stuff it's like kind of scary and
it's also there's something cool like if
my bed can somehow set my coffee to be
ready and get me up at the right time
and knows how much exercise I did so
that maybe I need more sleep that day or
like it's pretty cool right yeah I mean
when I watch this at first I thought it
was a joke when I watched it I thought
it was a joke yeah it looks like an SNL
sketch yeah it's it's incredible I don't
know I just want to know though like
does the Luna like if it'll make your
coffee will it show up at work for you
you know Luna read me a bedtime story or
tell my neighbor downstairs to turn off
this TV well will it spoon me well you
know word off you know one night Sam's
like oh that's interesting like Luna
like what do you think like we're always
talking about all this technology stuff
I've had you on a million times able to
talk about this and sometimes it feels
very cool and then sometimes it's like
whoa like is any of this making us
happier is any of this making us more
fulfilled I mean it's the NSA trying to
spy on every party or no I don't know to
me it's a little weird it's like you
know our bodies kind of know how to wake
ourselves up yeah at what point do we
like let you know normal human function
take over yeah
and I'm not a light sleeper I toss and
turn like is like I'm gonna wake up and
have like seven pots of coffee right
that's actually funny like you could end
up learning a lot about yourself this
thing is it right it's gonna be telling
you all kinds of crazy things so you
know you were joking about the NSA part
but I do think there's something about
this endless technology this endless
spying all the stuff that we talk about
that when you're in bed it's one of the
only times you know to me like even now
I I've said it a bunch of times lately
but like I'm trying not to have my phone
in my bed anymore or my iPad like it's
one of the only times when you
disconnect so even though this seems
kind of cool is that the element of it
that's kind of scary
that we're never gonna disconnect from
this app 24 hours yeah I mean like you
said your bed is like your Haven yeah
you just chill out and now it's all
connected it's a science experiment you
know and then what if there's more than
one Luna in a household are they gonna
like start mating and then the looters
are gonna take over right I mean you
said when are the robots yeah do they
multiply I just you're talking like
you're like you know 7.0 like what if
there's two in a house or what if like
it wants to shut the TV off and all that
crap and there's someone like watching
the TV downstairs it's like hey Ryan
well that's why I think your original
point is good we're so afraid of just
what our human processes are we wake up
you know generally they say you wake up
when your body has had enough sleep you
know any way that we're so and that's
what I think were maybe missing here
we're disconnecting ourselves there's
something about that I like actually
about the ritual of making coffee in the
morning with my French press and
grinding the beans like it's an actual
thing and eventually
it's almost like we're gonna become the
robots to the thing yeah just check out
like all the time you know yeah so final
thought on this would you guys be
interested in a technology vacation
because that's every time I see a new
one of these things or there's a new
social media thing I'm always like I
could use like a week off oh I thought
you meant like I was gonna go check into
a hotel that was all what would you like
that I miss the vacation from it but
really completely unplug yeah heaven
yeah let me do it I don't know man I'm
pretty attached it's awesome I mean like
yeah I don't know I live on the internet
kind of but I could I could unplug for
like a day or two a day or two all right
I mean okay we're gonna do a challenge
around here I've been thinking about it
lately we'll do like a group challenge I
will see what all you guys can do anyway
do you want to take a break from the
internet what do you think of Luna do
you like making your coffee let us know
in the comments right now